some potentially good news in the push
to reopen schools safely during this
pandemic
the cdc says classrooms can reopen if
teachers have not been vaccinated as
long as the covet protocols are met
san francisco is actually suing their
own school district to force reopenings
there
meg oliver has more on this story
day and niro cala orano's son amaru
started sixth grade this year
but he's never even stepped inside of
his middle school
it like all public schools in san
francisco
shut down at the height of the pandemic
teachers have refused to return
until a number of conditions are met
including a staff testing plan
and covet 19 prevention measures how do
you feel about the teachers unions
refusing to go back in person
i i think that's that's not right they
are not thinking about the kids
they are not thinking about um how
the kids are being impacted this has
become
omarou's primary classroom at the
beginning
he was engaged he was motivated
but then you know after all these months
they just lost san francisco backed by
mayor london breed
filed a lawsuit against its own school
district wednesday
in an attempt to force classrooms back
open
city officials point to more than a
hundred private and parochial schools
that have reopened with almost sixteen
thousand students attending
in-person classes and less than five
cases of suspected in-school
coveted transmission our kids are
suffering
and the inequalities that existed before
this pandemic
have only become more severe public
school teachers like megan calusa
say they're just as desperate to get
back to the classroom
but with proper safety protocols we're
relying on
our state government to provide
everything
that we have and we just haven't had
enough for now parents like calorano are
doing what they can to help their kids
even if it means moving remote learning
to a park
how does it make you feel uh it makes me
feel
kind of like i'm not even in school like
i'm just
on the computer sitting down waiting
teachers like megan calusa told us they
want regular testing for students
and staff and increased ventilation in
schools the
san francisco unified school
superintendent called the lawsuit
frivolous
insisting they do have a comprehensive
plan in place
lawsuits are multiplying nationwide here
in montclair new jersey
they became the first district in the
state this week to sue their teachers
union
after a staff shortage forced them to
cancel their reopening plan
in january guys meg thank you very much
a couple things that i know teachers are
saying because you live with it
because i live with the teacher um the
cdc did a study that basically says
it's okay to to send kids back to school
but that study was conducted in rural
wisconsin
so if you work in new york or chicago or
san francisco you're going it's the
circumstances are very different
the second is if you if bringing
teachers back into school and kids back
as a national priority and everybody
believes it should be
then get the teachers vaccinated yeah
absolutely just get them vaccinated
like a no-brainer does it right get them
vaccinated
front of the line right now yeah put
them at the front of the line get them
vaccinated that will that will ease a
lot of this
because right now everybody's suffering
the kids are suffering their parents are
suffering in the teachers
and my wife my wife spends eight hours
every day teaching
zoom classes and then immediately goes
online again to look for an appointment
for a vaccine
and cannot find one we should remember
the villain here is the virus yes
yes and everyone's united in that fight